وهذه
الاتهامات وضحتها ايضا للروسي بالوقوف
وراء اطلاق اثاروخ على بولندا محور وقفه
مع الحدث مع خالد الغرابلي خالد اهلا بك
استبعاد غربيه اذا مسؤوليه روسيا اليوم
على عكس التهامات التي استمعنا اليها
البارحه
ينفرد باتهام دائما موسكو ويقول انه لديه
دلائل ان هذا الصاروخ روسي وليس اوكرانيا
على الاطلاق رغم انه يفترض
يستطيعون قول ذلك لان الصاروخ همم سقط على
ارضه على كل الاحوال التصريحات كثيره جدا
وتبدو متضاربه بالامس اصابع الاتهام ووجهت
الى روسيا اليوم تبتعد عن روسيا ويقال انه
على الارجح صاروخ من منظومه الدفاع الجوي
الاوكرانينيا لكي نفهم الامور ربما اكثر
ان ان سمح الزملاء نرى الخريطه هناك بعض
الامور التي تثير الشوبها وغير منطقيه
وغير مفهوم على الاطلاق بمعنى ان راينا
همم الخارطه خلفي ان سمح الزمره يفترض ان
ساحه المواجهه على الحدود في في شرق وجنوب
همم اوكرانيا في هذه المنطقه وبالتالي ان
خرج صاروخ روسي من هذا المنطقه او من
الاراضي الروسيه يستهدف غرب اوكرانيا
والروس قالوا ان ابعد غاره لهم كانت على
بعض 35 كلم من هذه الحدود يفترض ان خرج
صاروخ للدفاع الجوي هو ان يسقط الصواريخ
الروسيه قبل ان تصل الى هذه المنطقه قبل
ان تصل الى مسافه تبعد عن الحدود بخمسه
وثلاثين كيلو متر لكن ما حدث ان الصواريخ
وقعت على او سقطت على الجهه الاخرى وهذا
يبدو غير منطقي على الاطلاق ما السبب قد
يكون هناك خطا عسكري لكن اقول قد نحن
نستطيع ان نقول هنا من باريس نحن لسنا على
الارض لكن ما يمكن ان نقوله نقول ان
التفسيرات التي تقدم من قبل معظم العواصم
الغربيه الان لا تبدو منطقيه الى حد كبير
كيف نحول ان نفهم سنقرا بين السطور ونار
الموقف الامريكي لماذا الموقف الامريكي
لان الوقت المتحده موجوده في هذه الحرب
على هذه الارض
بالاستخبارات بالاقمار الاصطناعيه
بعلاقاتها مع هذه الدول والتي تسمح لها
بمعرفه الكثير ما الذي حدث في سلوك
الولايات المتحده اول دوله خرجت منها
معلومه ان هناك صواريخ روسيه سقطت في قريه
بولنديه على الحدود الاوكرانيه خرجت من
وكاله انباء امريكيه نقلا عن مسؤول في
الاستخبارات الامريكيه
حدد هويه الصواريخ بانها صواريخ ان
صاروخين روسيين سقطاه اذا يفطر
بالاستخبارات عندما تتحدث بهذا الشكل او
يخرج منها مصدر يسري بهذه المعلومه هو
يتحدث عن معلومه وليس مجرد استنتاج بعدها
باقل من ساعه لتنتجون يقول انه يحقق في
الموضوع
بعد اقل من 24 ساعه يخرج بين ليقول ان
المعلومات الاوليه تستبعد فكره ان يكون
انطلق من روسيا واوربما يكون صاروخ
اوكراني ويشير الى التحقيق جاري طيب اذا
كان التحقيق لم يحسب موضوع بعد من اين حصل
الرئيس الامريكي على معلومات تناقض مسربته
لاستخبارات الامريكيه يبدو ان هذا التصريح
السياسي وليس عسكري تقني مبني على معلومات
طيب ماذا عن امين عام حلف الاطلسي الذي
خرج ايضا يؤكد او يرجح فرضيه انه صاروخ
اوكراني عندما سوء الامين عام حلف الاطلسي
عن مكان سقوط الصاروخ بالضبط في الاراضي
البولاديه وعما اذا كان هناك حطام لصاروخ
روسي او مقذوف فقط او مقذوفه روسيه ماذا
كان رد الرد كان انه رفض ان يجيب بكل
بساطه لكن من اجاب على مثل هذا السؤال حتى
بدون ان يطلب منها وزيره الدفاع بلجيكا
وان سمح زملا ان نرى ما الذي قالته وزيره
الدفاع البشريه بالضبط هي قالت في هذه
المرحله واستنادا الى المعلومات المتاحه
اذا هي لا تتحدث عن استنتاجات وانما عن
معلومات وهي وزير الدفاع لدوله عضو في
حاله الاطلسي تت مع الاستخبارات المعلومات
يبدو ان شظايا صواريخ روسيه وصواريخ
اوكرانيه مضاده للطائرات ضربت الاراضي
البولنديه اذن بحسب هذا التصريح هناك
صاروخ روسي وصل الى قريه بولنديه روسي
وليس اوكراني
طبعا اوكراني ايضا لكن الهدف انها تتحدث
عن وصول صاروخ روسي التحليليه عن ماذا
تدور التحليلات والتحقيقات اذا ان كان
هناك المعلومه ان صاروخ روسي سقط بالفعل
تقول التحريلات ما زالت جاريه لتحديد مصدر
الطلقات والاهداف التي كان من المقرر ان
تصل هذه الصواريخ اليها على وجه اليقين
يعني ما هو الهدف وفي النهايه تقول لا شيء
يدل على انه هجوم متعمد يعني ربما يكون
هجوم عن طريق الخطا همم ماذا عن بولندا
بولندا التي تريست في البدايه ولم ترغي في
توجيه التهاب الى روسيا اجتمعت مجلس الامن
القومي وبعدها عند منتصف الليل استدعت
السفير الروسي اجتماع لاربع دقائق بدون
مصافحه بدون مجاملات سالته عما تفعله
روسيا ومصدر في الخارجيه يقول اننا نفكر
في طرد السفير الروسي
اذا كانت المعلومات الاوليه تستبعد روسيا
وتتحدث عن حادث لماذا يستضعف السفير
الروسي
يفكر في طرده لماذا تعرض المانيا لتكون
هناك
طائرات المانيه تشارك في دوريات مشتركه
على حدود بولندا اوكرانيا نسبب ما يقوله
الرئيس الاوكرانيا الذي يبدو انه يريد
بحلف الاطلسي فعلا في هذا الحرب حتى وان
كان هذا معنا حرب عالميه نرى الان موقف
اوكرانيا ماذا تقول اوكرانيا نحن ننفي
المعلومات التي تقول انه صاروخ اوكراني
ونريد ان نشارك في التحقيق فورا لماذا لو
كان هو صاروخ اوكراني ربما كان سكته استاذ
مصطفى لكن قولنا نريد ان يشارك في الدقيقه
للكشف عن نتائج التحقيق التي ربما تاتي
بعكس ما يريد الامريكيون كيف كان ردد
بولندي علينا ان نحصل على موافقه الولايات
المتحده رغم انها اراضي بولنديه والسياده
بولنديه لكن واضح ان هناك ضغوط امريكيه
جعلت بولندا تقول مشاركه اوكرانيا في
التحقيق تحتاج الى موافقه نورك يا كل ذلك
يشير الى ان هناك شبه حقيقيه احتمال وجود
صواريخ روسيه وصلت بالفعل الى اراضي
بولندا لكن هناك رغبه في تغطيه الموضوع في
حاجه كانت تفاعلها روسيا ما يمكن ان تكون
ما وراء هذا صاروخ لماذا يستبعد الغرب كل
ذلك الان لانه بمجرد ان يكون هناك صاروخ
روسي وصل لابد ان يكون هناك رد الصم عن
صاروخ حتى لو بطريق الخطا هذا معناه موقف
ضعيف من حيث الاطلسي لابد ان يكون هناك رد
وان كان هناك رد لابد ان يكون هناك رد فعل
وهو بدايه الانطلاق ربما الى ما هو ما
اخطر ذلك والاسلم للجميع هو التجديد على
ان صاروخ اوكراني بدون الحديث عن اي صاروخ
روسي وبالتالي يتم تفادل الاسود شكرا لك
خالد الغرب على وقفه مع الحدث